fans are eagerly awaiting the super
hyped dc phantom event that is coming
out this weekend
and to pump us up even further warner
brothers and dc has sent us this mystery
box to share it with you guys
what's up everybody zacky here from geek
culture and we've got another unboxing
video and of course little more juicy
details on dc fandom so you guys can
stay hyped and ready we're sure the guys
over at dc expect some really awesome
goodies inside so without further ado
let's take a look we got very nice dc
logo here
and
the box itself this is
dc phantom
very nice
okay
and
we're gonna oh
it's it's it's velcro
without little boxes that come in velcro
right no need for pen knives and stuff
so the first thing that comes out is
this
awesome cool map here we have an
amusement park like map that showcases
the different venues
of dc fandom just to let you guys know
that the dc fandom event has expanded to
two global events the first on the 22nd
to 23rd of august which is the dc
phantom hall of heroes and the next one
is 12th to 13th of september which is
the dc fandom explore the multiverse
event the dates for the start of the
events depends on which time zone you
are in so be sure to check out our dates
and of course more information on our dc
coverage here at geek culture links in
the description below starting off the
hall of heroes this is where all the
major programming will happen such as
new content and panels of your favorite
dc shows movies and games the watch
verse that features four theaters
with tv show panels that consist of the
flash dome patrol and even lucifer and
where fans can watch hours and hours of
dc content there'll also be a slew of
screenings and live performances so
don't forget to check that out next is
the u-verse which displays fan art
cosplay
and other fan-made content inspired by
the characters in the dc universe you
can even get up and personal with the
legendary jin li with q a and portfolio
reviews
there will even be a q a session with
the cast of aquaman and suicide squad we
will also have insider verse where fans
can take a behind the scenes look at how
their favorite dc comics movies games
and more were created and going to the
fun verse this is an interactive space
where fans can enjoy free digital comics
buy merchandise and even participate in
other fun activities of course we have
something made for the kids this is the
kids verse featuring a teen titans tower
and a dc superhero girls sweet justice
cafe
you super moms and dads can finally
enjoy some sweet dc family time
or just distract your kids while you
enjoy the rest of the content
now moving on to
the other stuff in the box we've got
very plush dc tissue paper
and what we have here is the funko pop
wonder woman based on the justice league
movie
and like here
joining batman aquaman superman the
flash and cyborg
so yeah
let's unbox this and right
here
so what we have here is a dc phantom cap
and a very simple dc phantom shirt
so let's
[Music]
can you see the word panda
ray ray nice and simple
all day every day
so without further ado we are going to
change into these clothes
wow
how did that happen
so it's very nice comfortable material
really love the head digging it
feels so straight right now
hypebeast
ready to do that high beast thing just
like zoom in just zoom in
zoom
yeah
dc fan boy let's see what else is in the
box
oh
nothing much
guys
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we have exclusive
artwork signed and done up by jim lee
this is a 19
over 375 copies
and it features some artwork such as
black lightning
to flash wonder woman
cheetah starfire
and a lot of other characters with uh
teen titans at the back which is part of
the
the whole
universe thing i think this is the kid
verse what we're seeing right there so
yeah pretty cool
signed by jim lee
this is awesome
we gotta find a frame for this
but
yeah
awesome
so that's it guys we've unboxed the
entire thing and we hope you enjoyed
these little tidbits if you'd like to
know more about our coverage of the dc
phantom event links in the description
below and if you haven't already don't
forget to follow our social media
channels don't forget to like and share
this video with your friends if you
haven't already do consider subscribing
and smash that notification bell icon so
you can stay updated to our latest geeky
news and tidbits don't forget to drop a
comment down below and tell us what is
the biggest thing that you're excited
for at the dc venom event so from us at
geek culture this is zaki signing off
[Music]